e wie findet ihr die Qualität von Z die
geht es klar Sandra red mal ein bisschen
paar Sätze am Stück irgendwie erzähl mal
was hallo ich bin Sandra ja ich war
gessern feiern und habe mich extrem also
eigentlich habe ich gar nicht so viel
getrunken in meinem Kopf e alle
schreiben chatck mal ist Katastrophe
ehrlich rauscht ziemlich
katastrophal geht so 6 minus klingt wie
ein Toaster gefühlt kein Mikro gar nicht
reden heute ist es leider mal so weil
Sandra wie sie gerade schon gesagt hat
ziemlich gesoffen hat gestern ich kann
euch mal ein Foto zeigen wie Sandra
tatsächlich gestern geschlafen hat ist
am PC die ist einfach so eingeschlafen
dementsprechend hört sie sich auch an
und dementsprechend ist sie jetzt auch
gerade nicht im Office in in Bielefeld
sondern sitzt zu Hause mit dem Laptop
und airpods deswegen damit müssen wir
jetzt klar kommen die Quali von Sander
ist heute Scheiße okay dementsprechend
würde ich sagen wir gehen hier weiter
voran
und bauen soange
dies
was ist denn da
[Musik]
Laserer
lucaiveen ach
nein wie geil wie
süß oh mein
Gott Leute ratet ratet auch mal wer
morgen Urlaub fährt da brauchen Sie gar
nicht raten wissen e
wer ach du scheiße
Sandra warum bist du jetzt so random
gestorben Laser da kam ein Skelett und
du hast mich nicht du hast mir nicht
geholfen du bastarder ich verstehe die
teilweise gar nicht ne wie geht es dein
Nippel oh mein
Gott wer ist sie
denn was ist das
wer bist du denn wir brauchen wirklich
essen ich muss auch Fleisch essen anders
kriegen wir das hier nicht hin Sandra du
musst jetzt die Hühner töten oder soll
ich das machen Leute ich kann auch pa
Hühnchen töten eigentlich auch kein der
vegetarisch sein will bei
Minecraft das so dumm ja ich wei
wirklich dumm komm ich töte jetzt
einfach paar Hühner tut mir leid es ist
halt ein anderes Projekt es ist jetzt
nicht Minecraft loser oder irgendwie
Minecraft mit Luca wir brauchen ein
Essen ich hab mich ganz me Herz auf Jen
verf ich hab ke le iche überlegt soll
ich mit dem Rauchen aufhören sagst du
jedes mal wenn du verkart bist und
danachst du doppelt so viel ja ich will
mit ich ma neue Spitzhacke ich habe
meine noch ja
eisenspitzhack Bo OL geht direkt drauf
Wahnsinn oh nein das überlebst du oder
ne ja doch do seh g Alter wie die ganzen
Hühner da so gucken
einfach und du ist dabei
hun das seid ihr W ich die demonstrativ
vor denen so ein Hühnchen
[Musik]
Essen Sandra ich mache für deinen Hund
ein gelbes Halsband okay dann weißt Du
immer dass das deiner ist
hier wie kann ich ihm das jetzt anziehen
du musst das einfach mit Kuh auf ihn
drauf schmeißen
jetzt musst du so eine Minute warten bis
er das quasi genommen hat eine Ewigkeit
später also er macht mir gar nicht okay
sammel mal
auf probier es mal mit rechtsklick auf
ihm drauf
vielleicht schlag mal die Ziege und
bleib stehen was soll das
bringen mach das nicht Laser kann nichts
passieren die Arm
[Musik]
nein
was kann man das rückgängig machen prank
kommt ist geplant ein CP prank wie ich
Sandra
steuere das hier heißt Spieler
kontrollieren ich weiß nicht wie das
funktioniert oder ob es
funktioniert was
los was
los was ist ich verlassen was hast du
ich habe mein Körper
verlassen was ist denn ich habe mein
Körper verlassen ich bin nicht mehr in
meinem Minecraft Körper wieso bist du
nicht mehr in de Minecraft Körper keine
Ahnung oh mein Gott wie gruselig ich
glaub wir wurden gehackt nein das bin
ich wollte das mal testen ob das klappt
das klappt wirklich Biss parano hab das
mitbekommen kommt glaub ich gleich Hexe
s du mal weiter ab die Papageien hinten
voll süß Hexe kommt
ja oh oh
mal Olaf geht direkt
drauf einfach nie was zu tun mit
irgendwelchen Streitigkeiten das del die
einfach unter sich W ich jetzt do hier
hier den Hundi drauf
loslasse haben wir gar nichts mehr zu
tun lass die mal
machen was ist wer ist denn Olaf ist tot
ach du Scheiße nicht dass me h jetzt
auch noch
stirbt
guck mal nach vergammelen
Fleisch dann töte kurzcken geb ihm essen
alles gut der wird schaffen der wird
schaffen aber das hört nicht auf bei ihm
ich habe nicht mehr
essen oh nein wir haben nicht
mehr was hat er denn alles Gute danke er
hat überlebt das gibt doch gar nicht
Sand ich würde das jetzt so lassen hier
vorne mit unserem kistenraum wir haben
sechs riesige Kisten das sollte glaube
ich erstmal reichen für die bisherigen
Items wir müssen noch mal aufräumen weil
wir so viele auch eigentlich gar nicht
brauchen wie wir haben da würde ich
sagen sortieren wir jetzt noch mal eben
fix die Items rein wollen wir da links
wo Du gerade dran bist alle alle Stein
ne ich w holzschen ich daade schon Stein
rein warum sind da dann Korallen
drin ich bin doch ganz links das sind
Korallen die du da gerade rein machst
das sind abgestorbene
Korallen ja Scheiß
draufer
ohowow wir können mal eben kurz jetzt
probieren ob das jetzt klappt
[Musik]
hier ich habe ein Papagei ne wie unfair
und meiner tut mir leid kann man nichts
machen Leute es nimmt alles Form an
mittlerweile ne sehr cool ich bin ganz
ehrlich nach dem ersten Stream h one
dachte ich mir so h wo soll es hinführen
aber jetzt vor allem dass wir sehen Sand
heute fünfm gestorben ich zweimal das
haben wir jetzt drin wir hab jetzt
diesen ob Counter drin das heißt wir
sind beim Block 876 von 2400 das hat
sich ergeben wir können uns die Phasen
angucken wir sind gerade in der
dschungelphase danach kommt das
sumpfbiom du willst diesen Stress nicht
und und wir haben heute diesen
kistenraum hier gebaut nächstes Mal
werde ich dann mein kleinen mein kleines
Haus bauen wir werden die Farm erweitern
wir werden natürlich die Blöcke
weiterhin abbauen da vorne das Grün
werden wir ein bisschen schöner machen
vielleicht mit paar Pflanzen und dann
nimmt i alles langsam Form an so Leute
ich würde sagen das war's mit Minecraft
one block wir hoffen natürlich es hat
euch gefallen ich verabschiede mich hier
an der Stelle ihr seid der Hammer Laser
wir sehen und hören unds sie
Tage rein gute Besserung C ja Leute wir
sind Sonntag wieder live wie gesagt am
sinnvollsten wär es wenn ihr einfach
hier folgt denn dann passiert nichts und
ihr also ihr kriegt Benachrichtigung
dann einfach wenn es losgeht habe euch
lieb bis Sonntag haut rein
[Musik]
ciao